do you see what's the uh thing that
happened in uh texas with that governor
did you see that the mayor wrote that
note
texas mirror tells residents can you
zoom in there you go thank you uh
let me see by tuesday morning the
residents of colorado city texas were
getting anxious more than 24 hours had
passed since a deadly arctic blast
knocked out power across the state
residents turned to a community facebook
group to ask whether the small town plan
to open warming shelters while others
wondered if
firefighters could do their job without
water colorado's mayor chimed in
less than comforting message he said no
one owes you or your family anything
mayor tim boyd wrote i'm sick and tired
of people looking for a damn handout
what that the lazy residents find their
own ways of procuring water and
electricity immediately drew backlash
later on tuesday boyd announced his
resignation and admitted he could have
used better word how do you
procure electricity like what
right okay uh highlighted how one of the
worst winter storms in decades is
testing the limits
of the embrace of self-sufficiency and
rugged individualism in texas
so it's a good question man like i don't
know you know i was thinking about this
the other day
um so will you grab me an extra water by
chance thanks man
um how would you do survival well i was
thinking about this the other day so
i'm talking to my friend in louisiana
and he said oh there's rolling blackouts
so
some friends are coming over tonight
because we have power tonight right
i said okay that's interesting so it
made me think like
what if the power company i'll take the
death
so thanks brother so what if the power
company like
like the power company is not a
guarantee for like it's a it's part of
society that we've gotten to we're lucky
enough to have like this thing this
structure
you know but yeah like what if it went
out like
so i don't know where this mirror was
coming from i mean that's probably
certainly the best way to word things if
you're the leader
but i mean if it's people sitting in a
home they're freezing to death yeah and
it's
you know at some point you have to start
a fire for yourself or you have to go to
somebody's house that like you have to
also take action
true but you don't want your leader to
be like every man for himself
that's basically not the message you
know what i mean but that's a great
point
you know your leader is supposed to be
your leader let everybody else panic
but if you're panicking it's it's over
you know
i but it's one thing to tell people to
get water because there's snow outside
so you
know there's moisture you can figure
that out procure your
own electricity look i mean i wouldn't
even if
i would first of all have to google
procure i don't know exactly what it
means i think i do
i think it's how you treat ham yeah go
back get that back open
yeah let's go back to the yeah uh at
least 10 deaths in texas have been
linked to the winter storm since monday
according to houston chronicle
so yeah i mean it's wild i think i think
maybe this guy was probably just upset
about other
stuff and probably attached it to this
yeah
but if you were going to procure your
own electricity what would be your first
move i'd probably get a generator
gas power generator or i would start
burning stuff
i mean it's tough that's why burn it
outside because this
the storm is obviously gonna oh that's a
good point but you can't burn it
inside either because of the gas yeah
yeah you know what i mean so
the heat that's the thing that i i don't
know exactly
how people were doing it unless you had
the generator
right so yeah i think that's a good
point so i guess maybe they're thinking
yeah find other people that have
generators
i get it's also tough with this kind of
article you don't know if people's cell
phones are still working
you don't know if the roads are able
that people can drive on
um i wish they knew they would say what
set this man off
but yeah if you're the leader i think
you probably got to find a better way to
lead
yeah you can't you can't come out and be
like hey you [ __ ]
procure some electricity i'm like well i
don't even know what that means man
i don't have any electricity to google
procure so you're gonna have to break it
down for me a little better yeah
but if you're in your house yelling for
help but you also have legs at work it's
like
then that's on you also but i think one
of the big
issues we have in america today theo is
that people have
forgotten that two things can be true at
the same time
yeah two things can be true at the same
time you know whether you're talking
about
this pandemic where two things can be
true at the same time
do masks cure everything no they don't
you can still get it if you have a mask
yeah but is it possible that they help
yeah
right so there's two things people are
saying you're yelling at each other
and both of what you and i are saying
are the same are true
you know what i mean it's possible for
two things to be true this also
should you wait to die no but
is it up to you to procure electricity
yeah probably not not at first yeah do
you know what i mean like so i think
it's probably
that's the thing like we've we've
lost the ability to go yeah that can be
true what i'm saying
is also true but that can be true also
yeah there's no there's no
room for two sets of truths right which
most
things ha yeah most things have
two sides and most of the time both
those sides have
truth to them yeah that's why people are
so it's so easy to to pick a side now
right we're so tribal now
it's not that there aren't we can't find
facts there are too many facts available
yeah so i can find a fact that'll back
up whatever the [ __ ] i want to tell you
is true
i can find a fact online an article
online
a news site online that'll back me up
you know what that does that makes me
seem smart
that gives me a [ __ ] hill to stand on
so i never have to listen to you
oh yeah do you know what i mean i just
saw it online and everybody in your echo
chamber says the same thing so it must
be true
but both two things can be true at the
same time that's a good point man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one
you